This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vidantam. On June 4th, 1924, a girl was admitted to the Virginia State Colony for epileptics and feeble minded. She was white, dark-haired, and 17 years old. She became colony in May 1692. The medical superintendent of the colony examined her, he declared her healthy, free of syphilis, able to read, write, and keep herself tidy. And then he classified her as feeble-minded of the lowest grade, moron class. With that designation, this young woman, who had already lost more than many people
这里是 Hidden Brain，我是香卡·维丹特姆。1924年6月4日，一名女孩被送进了弗吉尼亚州癫痫与智力低下者收容所。她是个白人，黑头发，17岁。她于1692年5月进入该收容所。收容所的医疗主管对她进行了检查，宣布她身体健康，没有感染梅毒，能够识字、写字并保持整洁。然后，他将她归类为最低等级的智力低下者，即白痴级。带着这个称号，这个年纪轻轻就已经失去了比许多人
could bear in a lifetime, was set on a path she didn't choose. What happened next laid the foundation for one of the most tragic social experiments in American history, the forced sterilization of tens of thousands of people. This story has resonance even today. It's about how science and the law, tools that we have created to help improve our lives, can easily become instruments of prejudice and oppression. It's a story of hubris and about good intentions gone awry. Eugenics and the science of better breeding this week on Hidden Brain.
一生中能够承受的还要多的年轻女孩，踏上了一条她并未选择的道路。接下来发生的事情，为美国历史上最悲惨的社会实验之一——对数万人实施强制绝育——奠定了基础。这个故事在今天依然有着共鸣。它讲述了科学和法律——我们为改善生活而创造的工具——如何轻易地变成偏见和压迫的工具。这是一个傲慢的故事，也是一个好心办坏事的故事。优生学与优质繁育科学，本周 Hidden Brain 节目为您播出。
First of all, please tell me your name. Carrie, Elizabeth, Gettimo. In 1980, an NPR reporter Wendy Blair took a trip to a one-room shack outside Charlotte's ville, Virginia. She'd come to interview a 78-year-old woman. Her married name was Dede Moore, but her given name was Carrie Buck. You see, I was adapted for now as a little girl. I was adapted by the dubs, it's here in Shellville. This interview was one of the few that Carrie Buck ever gave.
首先，请告诉我你的名字。嘉莉·伊丽莎白·格蒂莫。1980年，NPR记者温迪·布莱尔前往弗吉尼亚州夏洛茨维尔市外的一间单间小屋。她来采访一位78岁的老妇人。她婚后的名字是迪迪·摩尔，但她的本名是嘉莉·巴克。你看，我小时候就被收养了。我是被多布斯夫妇收养的，就在谢尔维尔。这次采访是嘉莉·巴克接受过的为数不多的采访之一。
By this point, she had little to say. It was left to others to reconstruct her story. One of those who took up the task was historian and lawyer Paul Lombardo. He is the author of the book, Three Generations, No Embersils, Eugenics, The Supreme Court, and Buck V. Bell. Paul says the story of Carrie Buck really begins in the 19th century. Francis Galton was a cousin of Charles Darwin who came up with a theory of evolution. Francis Galton was interested in evolution, but he was more interested in what he saw as the applications of the science. His passion really, his driving force was to measure things and try to calculate how the future was going to play out in human behavior. I think the thing we know for the most now
到了这个时候，她已经无话可说了。重建她故事的任务落在了别人身上。承担这项任务的人之一是历史学家兼律师保罗·隆巴多。他是《三代人，绝无残疾：优生学、最高法院与巴克诉贝尔案》一书的作者。保罗说，嘉莉·巴克的故事真正开始于19世纪。弗朗西斯·高尔顿是查尔斯·达尔文的表弟，他提出了进化论。弗朗西斯·高尔顿对进化论很感兴趣，但他更感兴趣的是他所看到的科学应用。他的热情，也就是他的驱动力，是衡量事物，并试图计算人类行为在未来的发展方式。我想我们现在最了解的
are his coinage of the term eugenics, but also his real foundation of what we think of as modern statistical theory. When Galton introduced the idea of eugenics, what was his thinking? What was he aiming to do? As I said, he was looking a great deal at patterns of behavior and trying to figure out why it was that genius, the ability to think productively, and other abilities, how these clustered in families. And so we see him very early in his career suggesting that maybe there's a way of understanding this clustering of ability, and for that matter, disability in certain families, there must be something that is biological about it, something that's inherent to the organism.
是他创造了“优生学”这个词，以及我们今天所理解的现代统计学理论的真正基础。当高尔顿引入优生学的概念时，他的想法是什么？他的目标是什么？正如我所说，他大量研究行为模式，并试图弄清楚为什么天才、进行生产性思考的能力以及其他能力会在家族中聚集。因此，我们在他职业生涯的早期就看到他提出，也许有一种方法可以理解这种能力的聚集，以及某些家族中残疾的聚集，这里面一定有某种生物学的东西，某种有机体内在的东西。
And he proposes that this thing is really something you can think of as eugenics, which is a way of organizing people that will encourage the people who are prosperous and who are healthy and who are productive to marry other people of similar talents and then pass on their abilities to children. And at the same time, discourage people who are not successful and not productive, perhaps are poor, perhaps unwell, and over time, the negative ones will fall out of the population. To be fair, lots of people pair up with others who are similar in education and social class,
他提出，这个东西实际上可以被认为是优生学，这是一种组织人们的方式，它将鼓励那些繁荣、健康和富有生产力的人与具有类似才能的人结婚，然后将他们的能力传给孩子。与此同时，劝阻那些不成功、没有生产力、也许贫穷、也许健康状况不佳的人，随着时间的推移，负面的人口将会从人口中消失。平心而论，许多人会与教育和社会阶层相似的人结为伴侣，
but Francis Galton, writing in the early 20th century, wanted the state to get involved. I cannot doubt that our democracy will ultimately refuse consent to that liberty of propagating children, which is now allowed to the undesirable classes, but the popular says yet to be taught the true state of things. A democracy cannot endure unless it be composed of able citizens, therefore it must in self-defense withstand the free introduction of degenerate stock. These ideas coincided with a new movement in the United States. The progressive movement was an effort by social reformers to address the problems caused by industrialization.
但弗朗西斯·高尔顿在20世纪初写作时，希望国家介入进来。我毫不怀疑，我们的民主最终将拒绝默许目前允许不良阶层繁殖后代的自由，但公众仍有待学习事物的真实状态。一个民主国家如果不包含有能力的公民就无法持久，因此它必须进行自卫，抵制退化血统的自由引入。这些想法与美国的一场新运动不谋而合。进步运动是社会改革者为解决工业化带来的问题而做出的一项努力。
Progressives believed that education, science, and social institutions could solve society's greatest problems. They launched anti-corruption efforts, a drive for women's suffrage. They also started the colony movement,, institutions to care for and to detain people whom they viewed as disabled or deranged. The primary motive was compassion. People who ran institutions realized that with a growing population they had more and more people who were in need of care. So the colony movement begins as a movement out into the country. And then later starts to take on the new ideas of eugenics.
进步主义者认为，教育、科学和社会制度可以解决社会最大的问题。他们发起反腐败运动，争取妇女选举权。他们还启动了收容所运动，建立机构来照顾和拘留他们认为是残疾或精神失常的人。主要动机是同情。经营机构的人意识到，随着人口增长，越来越多的人需要照顾。因此，收容所运动最初是一项走向乡村的运动。后来开始吸收优生学的新思想。
Those ideas saying that people who are unfit, people who have mental or physical disabilities, people who are to use the language of the time, people minded, or morons, or imbistles should be separated and segregated from the general population, not only because they can't survive in the city, but also because that will keep them from reproducing. In 1911, Virginia opened its first colony just outside the small city of Lynchburg. Initially, the colony only took in people with epilepsy but soon new buildings went up to house people with
这些想法认为，不适合生育的人、有精神或身体残疾的人、用当时的话来说是智障、白痴或笨蛋的人，应该与普通人群分开并隔离，不仅因为他们在城市里无法生存，还因为这能阻止他们繁殖后代。1911年，弗吉尼亚州在小城林奇堡郊外开设了第一家收容所。最初，该收容所只收容癫痫患者，但很快新建筑拔地而起，用于收容
mental, physical, even moral defects. Women were often taken to colonies in the early years of the colony movement because they appeared to be sexually promiscuous or there were concerns that they were so unable to control themselves and so weak of mind and disposition that they needed to be protected and that the rest of the population needed to be protected from them. I reached out to Virginia historian Lynn Reinville. She says it's impossible to disentangle the Eugenics movement from the long history of men trying to regulate the behavior and bodies of women.
有精神、身体甚至道德缺陷的人。在收容所运动的早期，妇女经常被带到收容所以及她们似乎表现出性放荡，或者人们担心她们如此无法控制自己、思想和性格如此软弱，以至于需要受到保护，并且需要保护其他人免受她们的侵害。我联系了弗吉尼亚历史学家林恩·赖恩维尔。她说，不可能将优生运动与男性试图规范女性行为和身体的悠久历史割裂开来。
This was an attack against women. It's men making a plan of attack to deal with an issue that they have defined and targeting women. Just the way the birth control discussion is today, it's always assumed that it's the woman's responsibility and then something goes wrong, it's a woman's fault, and that if we have to control something, we've got to control women.
这是对女性的攻击。这是男性制定攻击计划来处理他们所定义的问题，并将女性作为目标。就像今天的避孕讨论一样，人们总是认为这是女性的责任，然后如果出了问题，那就是女性的错，如果我们必须控制什么，我们就必须控制女性。
When the Virginia colony first opened, demand for admission was high. At the time, people suffering from mental and physical disabilities were often shunted after the poor house or to a local jail. The colony seemed like a far more humane option. Paul Lombarder says the superintendent of the colony, Dr. Albert Pretty, took his mission seriously. Dr. Pretty believed that it was his prerogative as a physician, and especially a physician
当弗吉尼亚收容所刚开业时，对入住的需求很高。当时，患有精神和身体残疾的人经常被送到贫民窟或当地监狱。收容所看起来是一个更人道的人性化选择。保罗·隆巴多说，收容所的主管阿尔伯特·普里蒂医生非常认真地对待他的使命。普里蒂医生认为，作为一名医生，尤其是作为一名医生，这是他的特权
paid by the state to take care of the social problems that were generated by the individuals who came to the Virginia colony. And Dr. Pretty thought the best way to do that was first of all, by segregating them away from society and away from each other. They couldn't have children if they couldn't have sex. But secondly and more radically, he was one of the early people to propose surgical sterilization. The idea of forced sterilizations sounds shocking today.
由国家出资来照顾弗吉尼亚收容所的个人所产生的社会问题。普里蒂医生认为最好的方法是，首先将他们与社会隔离开来，并彼此隔离。如果他们不能发生性行为，他们就不能生孩子。但其次，更激进的是，他是最早提出外科绝育手术的人之一。强制绝育的想法在今天听起来令人震惊。
It was also shocking to many people in the early 20th century. Decenters fought eugenics on religious and legal grounds, but it also appealed to many ordinary citizens. The majority of people in the country, at least up until 1920, had grown up on farms. And everybody thought they understood how generation worked. The birds and the bees and the bulls and the cows and all the animals on the farm all reproduced as did all the crops. And people who lived on farms understood that you called the herd of the weaker members.
在20世纪初，这也让许多人感到震惊。反对者以宗教和法律为由反对优生学，但它也吸引了许多普通公民。该国的大多数人，至少在1920年之前，都在农场长大。每个人都认为自己理解世代是如何运作的。飞禽走兽、公牛母牛以及农场里的所有动物都像所有庄稼一样繁衍后代。住在农场里的人都明白，你要淘汰较弱的成员。
You got rid of the plant that was rotting in the field. You weeded your garden so as to get rid of the kinds of organisms that would ruin the whole plot. Gradually, states began enacting eugenics laws. In 1907, Indiana passed the country's first compulsory sterilization law. It applied to institutionalized criminals, rapists, idiots, and imbosils. Thirty-one states followed with their own laws. Diseases that might qualify a person for sterilization include its syphilis, alcoholism, moral or sexual perversion, and feeble mindedness. Virginia was not one of the early states to pass a eugenics law.
你要除掉田地里腐烂的植物。你给花园除草，以除掉会毁坏整块地的生物。渐渐地，各州开始颁布优生学法律。1907年，印第安纳州通过了该国第一部强制绝育法。它适用于被收容的罪犯、强奸犯、痴呆儿和白痴。三十一个州纷纷效仿，制定了自己的法律。可能使一个人有资格进行绝育的疾病包括梅毒、酗酒、道德或性倒错以及智力低下。弗吉尼亚州并不是较早通过优生学法律的州之一。
Nonetheless, around 1915, Dr. Albert Pretty began to sterilize some of his patients. He felt he had the authority based on a number of Virginia laws, which had fairly vague language in them, giving the directive to physicians who worked in state institutions, the power to do whatever was necessary for the medical health of a patient. He sterilized quite a number of them over a dozen, and then he was suddenly met with a lawsuit by a family of a man from the Eastern part of Virginia whose wife and two daughters had been taken to the colony while he was out of town. The man bringing the lawsuit was George Mallory.
尽管如此，在大约1915年，阿尔伯特·普里蒂医生开始对一些病人实施绝育手术。他觉得自己有权根据弗吉尼亚州的许多法律行事，这些法律的语言相当含糊，赋予在国家机构工作的医生权力，去做对病人医疗健康有必要的事情。他给相当多的人做了绝育手术，有十几个之多，然后他突然遭到弗吉尼亚州东部一个男人的家庭的起诉，该男人的妻子和两个女儿在他不在城里时被带到了收容所。提起诉讼的人是乔治·马洛里。
George was working on a sawmill in a little town outside of Richmond and was gone from home for several weeks at a time. He had a fairly large family with several daughters and a wife. And when he came back from work one weekend, he saw that most of his family was gone. Some of his children had been sent to foster care and his wife and two of his daughters had been taken to the Virginia colony.
乔治在里士满郊外一个小镇的一家锯木厂工作，每次离家几个星期。他有一个相当大的家庭，有几个女儿和一个妻子。当他周末下班回家时，他发现他的大部分家人都不见了。他的一些孩子被送到寄养家庭，他的妻子和两个女儿被带到了弗吉尼亚收容所。
It turns out that the social workers and the police had been watching their home and they made the allegation that the social workers and the police had been watching their home and they made the allegation that the Mallory family was running a house of ill repute or a brothel. And that's why they broke the family up while George was gone. George went and found a local lawyer told him his story. And that lawyer brought a case against Dr. Priti. Albert Priti was furious. Here he was, a man of science and reason, being challenged by someone who was not his social or intellectual equal. He never quite got
原来社会工作者和警察一直在监视他们的家，他们指控社会工作者和警察一直在监视他们的家，并指控马洛里一家经营着一家声名狼藉的房子或妓院。这就是为什么他们在乔治不在的时候拆散了这个家庭。乔治去找了一位当地的律师，把他的故事告诉了他。这位律师对普里蒂医生提起诉讼。阿尔伯特·普里蒂勃然大怒。在这里，他是一个科学和理性的人，却受到一个在社会或智力上与他不对等的人的挑战。他从未完全释怀
over the fact that he'd been dragged into the court by this poor man, when he thought he was doing the best thing, both for the state and for those women whom he sterilized. A jury refused to award damages to George Mallory, but the trial judge only won the doctor to stop what he was doing. Current Virginia law, the judge said, was not in the superintendent's favor. Eugenics was still illegal in Virginia. Albert Priti's response, he decided to change that. He began to campaign for a Virginia law that would explicitly allow for the sterilization of defective people. Among other things, he argued such a law could save taxpayer money. Instead of confining people to the colony, sterilized people could be sent back to communities. In 1924, his efforts paid off. Virginia passed a broad sterilization law. It gave eugenicists the green light.
他被这个穷人拖上了法庭，而他当时认为自己正在做最好的事情，既为了国家，也为了那些被他绝育的女性。陪审团拒绝向乔治·马洛里判给损害赔偿金，但审判法官只是赢得了医生停止他的做法。法官说，现行的弗吉尼亚法律对主管不利。优生学在弗吉尼亚仍然是非法的。阿尔伯特·普里蒂的回应是，他决定改变这种状况。他开始为一项弗吉尼亚法律竞选，该法律将明确允许对有缺陷的人进行绝育。除其他外，他辩称这样一项法律可以节省纳税人的钱。与其把人关在收容所里，不如把绝育的人送回社区。1924年，他的努力得到了回报。弗吉尼亚州通过了一项广泛的绝育法。这为优生学家开了绿灯。
But Albert pretty and others feared that even this wasn't enough. What if someone challenged the law, tried to overturn it? They wanted something watertight. They wanted not just a law, but a law that was sure to survive legal challenge. So they came up with an unusual strategy.
但阿尔伯特·普里蒂和其他人担心，即使这样也不够。如果有人挑战法律，试图推翻它怎么办？他们想要万无一失的东西。他们不仅想要一项法律，而且想要一项肯定能在法律挑战中存活下来的法律。于是他们想出了一个不同寻常的策略。
They decided to find a test case that they were absolutely sure to win. A case where, in effect, they would get to play both prosecution and defense. How to find such a case? Dr. Albert Pretty had just a person in mind. Her name was Carrie Buck. Stay with us. Carrie Buck must have realized from the time she was just a child that she didn't have much power or say about what happened to her.
他们决定找一个他们绝对有把握赢的测试案例。在这个案例中，实际上他们将同时扮演控方和辩方。如何找到这样一个案例？阿尔伯特·普里蒂医生心中正好有人选。她叫嘉莉·巴克。请继续收听。嘉莉·巴克从还是个孩子的时候起一定就意识到，她对自己身上发生的事情没有什么权力或发言权。
She was born in 1906 to Emma Buck, a woman who fell on hard times. Someone who, from time to time, was homeless, someone who was suspected of being a drug abuser. When Carrie was about four, local authorities removed her from Emma's care and placed her in a foster home. The family that became her foster parents were the dobs. And the dobs were also a very modest crew. They took her in partially because she could provide services as a household worker, and also because they got a bit of a supplement from the state for taking care of her.
她于1906年出生于埃玛·巴克，一个遭遇困境的女人。一个不时无家可归的人，一个被怀疑吸毒的人。嘉莉大约四岁时，当地当局将她从埃玛的照顾中带走，并把她安置在一个寄养家庭里。成为她养父母的家庭是多布斯夫妇。多布斯夫妇也是一个非常简朴的家庭。他们收留她，部分是因为她可以作为家政工人提供服务，也因为他们收留她可以从国家得到一点补贴。
Carrie lived with John and Alice Dobbs for more than a decade. She attended school and school records show. She was good at her lessons. But she left school after the sixth grade, She attended school and school records show. She was good at her lessons. But she left school after the sixth grade, and she spent her time as a domestic servant there in the Dobbs family. At 16, Carrie became pregnant. Her account of what happened never wavered. She says Alice Dobbs had left town to care for a sick relative. And at that point, a young man named Clarence Garland appeared. He was a nephew of Alice Dobbs. Carrie said Clarence took advantage of me.
嘉莉和约翰·多布斯以及爱丽丝·多布斯一起生活了十多年。她上过学，学校记录显示。她功课很好。但她在六年级后辍学，她上过学，学校记录显示。她功课很好。但她在六年级后辍学，她在多布斯家里做女佣来打发时间。16岁时，嘉莉怀孕了。她对所发生事情的叙述从未动摇过。她说爱丽丝·多布斯离开小镇去照顾生病的亲戚。就在那时，一个名叫克拉伦斯·加兰的年轻男子出现了。他是爱丽丝·多布斯的侄子。嘉莉说克拉伦斯利用了我。
He promised me he would marry me. He forced himself on me, and then he left. It was a huge scandal. Alice Dobbs knew that having an unmarried pregnant girl in the house looked very bad. It would jeopardize the family's chances of getting other foster placements. So she said about finding a way to have Carrie removed. And she asked the local social worker and the nurse and some doctors if they could have her committed
他向我保证他会娶我。他强迫了我，然后他就走了。这是一场巨大的丑闻。爱丽丝·多布斯知道家里有一个未婚怀孕的女孩看起来非常糟糕。这会危及这个家庭获得其他寄养名额的机会。于是她着手寻找让嘉莉离开的方法。她请当地的社工、护士和一些医生看看是否能把她送进
to the Virginia colony for the epileptic and the feeble minded, because that's often where girls like Carrie who were in trouble went. The moral overlay in the late 19th and early 20th century having to do with sex is just impossible to escape. The people who set up the colonies who thought that they could isolate people who were sexually promiscuous or for that matter who were somehow sexually unorthodox in other ways. They really focused on the necessity of getting those people out of society. Carrie was allowed to remain in Charlottesville until she gave birth.
弗吉尼亚州癫痫和智力低下者收容所，因为像嘉莉这样惹上麻烦的女孩通常都去了那里。19世纪末和20世纪初围绕性的道德外衣是根本无法逃避的。那些建立收容所的人认为他们可以隔离那些性放荡的人，或者在这方面以其他方式性异端的人。他们真的专注于把这些人赶出社会的必要性。嘉莉被允许留在夏洛茨维尔直到她生下孩子。
Alison John Dobbs agreed to take in the baby, a little girl named Vivian. Carrie was taken to the colony. Now this is the point in the story where the plot takes a very strange turn. You see Carrie's mother was already living at the same colony, Emma had been brought there a few years earlier. The stage was set for the tragedy that was about to unfold. Well, when Kerry arrived at the colony, Dr. Priti was quite excited because he had the records of Kerry's analysis and an examination by a Red Cross nurse who
爱丽丝和约翰·多布斯同意收养这个婴儿，一个小女孩叫薇薇安。嘉莉被带到了收容所。现在，这是故事中情节发生非常奇怪转折的一点。你看嘉莉的母亲已经住在同一个收容所里了，埃玛几年前被带到那里。悲剧即将上演的舞台已经搭好。好吧，当凯瑞到达收容所时，普里蒂医生非常兴奋，因为他有凯瑞的分析记录以及一位红十字会护士的检查记录
was living in Charlottesville and he he knew the records of Carrie's mother, Emma. And so all of the cluster of problems that Emma exhibited fit into Dr. Pritties' idea of the kinds of traits, the kind of negative traits that were hereditary, a woman who was sexually promiscuous, who had problems with her own inhibitions, who couldn't control her intake of things like alcohol and drugs, and who didn't take care of her children. He thought that these were characteristics that were likely to be passed down. So when Carrie appeared as a new resident of the colony,
她住在夏洛茨维尔，她知道嘉莉的母亲埃玛的记录。因此，埃玛表现出的所有一堆问题都符合普里蒂医生关于遗传特征的想法，即那种具有遗传性的负面特征，一个性生活混乱、自我抑制有问题、无法控制自己摄入酒精和药物等东西、并且不照顾自己孩子的女人。他认为这些特征很可能是遗传下来的。因此，当嘉莉作为收容所的新居民出现时，
and he connected the two people, it seemed to him that there might be good evidence here of a hereditary connection. Albert pretty knew that two generations with genetic flaws presented a strong case for sterilization, but three generations that would seal the deal. The third generation was Carrie's daughter Vivian, whom he automatically assumed was feeble-minded. The eugenicists had their case. They ignored facts that didn't fit, like Harry's normal school record. Harry was given a rudimentary IQ test, which came back suspiciously low. The mental age, they assigned to her, the number, I should say, the IQ number they assigned
他把这两个人联系起来，在他看来，这里可能存在遗传联系的良好证据。阿尔伯特·普里蒂知道，两代人有基因缺陷就为绝育提供了强有力的理由，但三代人就能一锤定音。第三代是嘉莉的女儿薇薇安，他自动认为她智力低下。优生学家们有了他们的案子。他们忽视了不符合事实的事实，比如哈里的正常学校记录。哈里接受了一次初级的智商测试，结果低得可疑。他们分配给她的心理年龄，这个数字，我应该说，他们分配给她的智商数字
to her was something in the 50s. If 70 is the cutoff for someone we would call developmentally disabled, or they might call them moron, she was 20 points below that. For Albert Pretty, the path was obvious. The first step under the new Virginia law was to petition the colony board for authorization to sterilize Carrie. He argued that she was incurable, had a mental age of a nine-year-old, and had given birth to a child born out of wetlock who was, quote, mentally defective.
到她身上的是50多岁。如果70岁是我们所说的发育障碍者的分水岭，或者他们可能称他们为白痴，她比那个数字低了20分。对阿尔伯特·普里蒂来说，道路是显而易见的。根据弗吉尼亚州的新法律，第一步是向收容所董事会请愿，授权对嘉莉进行绝育。他辩称她无法治愈，心理年龄只有九岁，并且生下了一个非婚生子，用他的话说，“精神上有缺陷”。
The board agreed that sterilizing Carrie was the right course. The next step to building a watertight case for sterilization was to have the board's decision challenged in the courts. The idea was to mount a legal challenge against eugenics, where the eugenics could play about attack and defense. They would defeat the challenge and thus establish a legal precedent. So Albert pretty recruited a friendly lawyer, a personal confidant, who would sue him on Carrie's behalf.
董事会同意对嘉莉进行绝育是正确的做法。建立一个万无一失的绝育案的下一步，是让董事会的决定在法庭上受到挑战。这个想法是发起针对优生学的法律挑战，优生学家可以在其中扮演进攻和防守的角色。他们将击败挑战，从而建立法律先例。因此，阿尔伯特·普里蒂招募了一位友好的律师，一个个人知己，由他代表嘉莉起诉他。
The lawyer was himself a proponent of Eugenics. He filed the appeal and Carrie's name, but never really represented her. She was just a prop. We really have no contemporaneous record of Carrie's thoughts. We have a picture of her, taken the day before her trial, which tells us a little bit, it tells us that she was a 17-year-old girl who seemed to be fairly uncomfortable and clearly in distress. She'd had a baby taken from her only a few months earlier. She was taken out of her home and sent away to a place she'd never been.
这位律师本人就是优生学的支持者。他以嘉莉的名义提交了上诉，但从未真正代表她。她只是一个道具。我们真的没有嘉莉想法的同期记录。我们有一张她的照片，是在她受审前一天拍的，这向我们透露了一点信息，它告诉我们她是一个17岁的女孩，似乎相当不舒服，明显处于痛苦之中。几个月前，她的一个孩子刚被夺走。她被带离家乡，送到一个她从未去过的地方。
She was surrounded by doctors and lawyers and other people who were prodding her and questioning her. So one would expect that a small town, Virginia girl, without a whole lot of education, with no one to protect her, would probably be afraid and distressed. And that's what she looks like in that picture. During the first trial at the Amherst County Courthouse, the Buck family was excoriated. Amher Buc was accused of living in the worst neighborhoods and functioning like a 12-year-old.
她周围都是医生、律师和其他对她指指点点、盘问她的人。因此，人们会期望一个没有受过太多教育、没有保护她的小镇弗吉尼亚女孩可能会感到害怕和痛苦。这就是她在照片里的样子。在阿默斯特县法院的第一次审判中，巴克一家受到了严厉谴责。阿默斯特·巴克被指控住在最糟糕的街区，表现得像个12岁的孩子。
A welfare worker who'd never met Carrie testified that she didn't seem to be a bright girl. Another social worker offered her assessment of Carrie's seven-month-old daughter Vivian. She said, There's a look about it that's not quite normal, but just what it is I can tell. Finally, Albert pretty testified that sterilizing women like Carrie might quote, tame them down. The trial took less than five hours.
一个从未见过嘉莉的福利工作者作证说，她看起来不像个聪明的女孩。另一位社工对嘉莉七个月大的女儿薇薇安进行了评估。她说，它有一种看起来不太正常的外表，但具体是什么我说不出来。最后，阿尔伯特·普里蒂作证说，对像嘉莉这样的女性进行绝育可能会“驯服”她们。审判持续了不到五个小时。
The county court upheld the sterilization order. But it wasn't enough for the eugenesis. Carry box lawyer appealed the case. While the case was still in the lower courts, Albert pretty died of Hodgkin's disease. A new doctor, John Bell, took over a superintendent of the colony. His name replaced his predecessor in the lawsuit. At every step, courts upheld the decision to sterilize Kerry. Finally, in 1926, the US Supreme Court accepted the case for review. This was a very important step because if the Supreme Court didn't endorse
县法院维持了绝育令。但这对于优生学家来说还不够。凯瑞·巴克的律师对该案提起了上诉。当此案仍在下级法院审理时，阿尔伯特·普里蒂死于霍奇金淋巴瘤。一位新医生约翰·贝尔接任收容所所长。他的名字在诉讼中取代了他的前任。在每一个步骤中，法庭都维持了对凯瑞进行绝育的决定。最终，在1926年，美国最高法院受理了此案进行审查。这是非常重要的一步，因为如果最高法院不赞同
sterilization, then it was still possible for someone to challenge the lower court law, and so they ended up in 1926 filing papers in the United States Supreme Court on behalf of Kerry, challenging the case and allowing the Supreme Court to take a look at all the evidence that had been gathered at the steps below. On May 2, 1927, in an 8-1 decision, the Court ruled a carry-buck could be sterilized. The opinion was written by Justice Oliver Wendell Holmes, Jr. He described the buck's family with cascading problems, generation to generation, a series of people who've had illegitimate children,
绝育手术，那么任何人仍然有可能对下级法院的法律提出挑战，因此他们在1926年最终代表凯瑞向美国最高法院提交了文件，对该案提出挑战，并允许最高法院审查在下面收集的所有证据。1927年5月2日，最高法院以8比1的投票结果裁定可以对凯瑞·巴克进行绝育手术。裁决书由大法官小小威廉·霍姆斯撰写。他将巴克一家的层层问题描述为代代相传，一系列生下私生子的家庭，
a series of people who seem to be mentally compromised and morally degraded mother child, and then grandchild, all somehow touched with mental defect. And Holmes wraps this all up into one package and says, it's better for all the world if instead of waiting for a degenerate offspring to die from starvation or for criminals to be executed for the crimes that we stopped this line before it goes on, better that those people not be born at all. And he describes the Buck family in his opinion, and draws a line under it and says, here we have three people, three generations, a whole household full of defect, three generations of imbussels are enough. Three generations of imbussels are enough. This phrase was to
一连串精神受损和道德堕落的母亲、孩子，然后是孙子，都以某种方式带有精神缺陷。霍姆斯把这一切打包在一起说：“为了全世界好，与其等待退化的后代饿死，或者让罪犯因罪行而被处决，不如我们在这一代人继续下去之前斩断这条血脉，最好这些人根本就不出生。”他在裁决书中描述了巴克一家，并在下面划了一条线说：“在这里我们有三个人，三代人，一整户充满缺陷的人，三代白痴就够了。”三代白痴就够了。这句话将
become the rallying cry of the Eugenics movement. On October 19, 1927, Carrie Buck was taken from her room at the Virginia Colony and brought to the infirmary. Dr. John Bell was waiting for her. Carrie received anesthesia and drugs to keep her from vomiting. When reporter Wendy Blair interviewed Carrie in 1980, she asked her about that day, and whether her doctor had told her what was happening. We only said that I wanted to leave, said that I would have to go through the operation, but I didn't want the operation. I kicked against it.
成为优生运动的集结号。1927年10月19日，嘉莉·巴克被带出她在弗吉尼亚收容所的房间，带到了医务室。约翰·贝尔医生在等她。嘉莉接受了麻醉和药物治疗，以防止她呕吐。1980年记者温迪·布莱尔采访嘉莉时，向她询问了那天的情况，以及她的医生是否告诉她发生了什么。我们只说我想离开，说我必须经历手术，但我不想做手术。我对此进行了反抗。
But it was useless. Everyone, the state, the country, even the Supreme Court, said Carrie's opinion about what happened to her own body mattered less than the opinions of doctors, politicians, and judges. Dr. Bell, having prepared Carrie for surgery, makes an incision in her abdomen, which exposes her fallopian tubes. He then cuts the tubes, ties them together, and soars her up. It takes several days for her to recover because this is after all major surgery. When she's recovered, she realizes
但这是徒劳的。每个人——国家、国家，甚至最高法院——都说嘉莉对她自己身体发生的事情的看法，不如医生、政客和法官的看法重要。贝尔医生在为嘉莉做手术准备时，在她的腹部切开了一个切口，露出了她的输卵管。然后他切断输卵管，把它们绑在一起，然后缝合起来。她需要几天时间才能恢复，因为这毕竟是大手术。当她康复时，她意识到
that she's had the surgical operation that would make her sterile. Carrie was 21 years old. And you remember how you felt? I didn't feel too good over it. Were you very sad? Yeah, I said it because I was very curious. Carrie was released from the Virginia colony soon after her sterilization. She married twice.
她接受了使她绝育的外科手术。嘉莉21岁。你还记得你当时的感受吗？我对这感觉不太好。你当时很难过吗？是的，我说很难过，因为我很奇怪。嘉莉在绝育后不久就从弗吉尼亚收容所释放了。她结过两次婚。
Her first marriage lasted 25 years until her sterilization. She married, twice. Her first marriage lasted 25 years until her husband died. She was still married to her second husband and living in a nursing facility when Paul Lombardo finally spoke with her in December 1982. She was quite near death. It wasn't clear that she was going to die, but she did about three weeks later. She was very weak, that she was going to die, but she did about three weeks later. She was very weak, and she wasn't very talkative. So, we really didn't talk about the details of her surgery. We did talk about her recollection of the time, and she made it obvious to me that she felt that she had been wronged, because the young man who had forced himself upon her, as she said, disappeared. She was left alone.
她的第一段婚姻持续了25年，直到她的丈夫去世。当保罗·隆巴多在1982年12月最后一次与她交谈时，她仍然与她的第二任丈夫结婚，并住在一家疗养院里。她已经濒临死亡。目前尚不清楚她是否会死，但她大约在三周后去世了。她非常虚弱，会死的，但她在三周后确实去世了。她很虚弱，不是很健谈。所以，我们真的没有谈论她手术的细节。我们确实谈到了她对那段时期的回忆，她向我表明，她觉得自己受到了冤枉，因为那个正如她所说强迫她的年轻男子消失了。她被孤立了。
No one protected her and no one defended her. No one protected Carrie Bucks younger sister, either. Her name was Doris. She'd also been brought to the colony on grounds that, quote, sooner or later, she will become the mother of illegitimate children. She was 12. She was registered as inmate 1968. Doris was sterilized about a year and a half later. Medical staff only told the child that she needed to have her appendix removed. NPR's Wendy Blair tracked down Doris and her
没有人保护她，也没有人替她辩护。也没有人保护嘉莉·巴克的妹妹。她叫多里斯。她也被带到了收容所，理由是“迟早她会成为私生子的母亲”。她12岁。她被登记为1968号院友。多里斯在大约一年半后被绝育。医务人员只告诉这个孩子她需要切除阑尾。NPR的温迪·布莱尔找到了多里斯和她的
husband Matthew Figgins for her report. Doris said that for decades she hadn't understood what had been done to her. I just love killing and I want it. Why? We want to kill them so bad. Doris and Matthew Figgins, who tried all their married life to have children, are both in their 60s now living in the country in Western Virginia. They visited many doctors before one told them not very clearly that Dara probably couldn't have a child. Dr. Hansberry had found scar tissue that she wouldn't be able to have a child.
丈夫马修·菲金斯进行采访。多里斯说，几十年来她一直不明白对她做了什么。我只是喜欢杀人，我想要它。为什么？我们太想杀了他们了。多里斯和马修·菲金斯一生都在努力生孩子，现在都60多岁了，住在弗吉尼亚州西部的乡村。他们拜访了许多医生，直到其中一位不太清楚地告诉德拉可能无法生孩子。汉斯伯里医生发现了疤痕组织，她将无法生孩子。
He didn't know. He didn't say that she had been sterile or anything. And today the figs still feel their disappointment. I felt empty, that's all. It wasn't until 1979 that Doris learned that she had been sterilized. The person who told her the news was the director of the colony at the time. His name was K. Ray Nelson. I felt that she had a right to know.
他不知道。他没有说她已经绝育什么的。今天，菲金斯夫妇仍然感到失望。我感到空虚，就这样。直到1979年，多里斯才知道自己被绝育了。告诉她这个消息的人是当时收容所的主任。他的名字叫K·雷·纳尔逊。我觉得她有权知道。
And basically that was my motive. She had a right to know. What is your understanding now about why they did that to you back then in 1928? I couldn't tell you. I don't know why. What did the sperm end on us? What? Guinea pigs.
基本上这就是我的动机。她有权知道。你现在对他们当年在1928年对你做那些事的原因有什么理解？我没法告诉你。我不知道为什么。精子对我们有什么用？什么？小白鼠。
And what a Vivian carries daughter. She'd been adopted by John and Alice Dobbs. According to the Supreme Court, she was the third generation of imbeciles and the Buck family. Vivian went to school. She went to the first grade and did passively well. She went to the second grade. That passively well. She went to the second grade. That summer, she got the measles, apparently developed some kind of secondary infection, and died when she was only eight years old. So her story was pretty much buried for the better
薇薇安和嘉莉的女儿呢？她被约翰和爱丽丝·多布斯收养了。根据最高法院的裁决，她是巴克家族的第三代白痴。薇薇安去上学了。她上了一年级，表现还算及格。她上了二年级。那个及格。她上了二年级。那年夏天，她得了麻疹，显然并发了某种继发感染，在只有八岁时就去世了。所以她的故事基本上被埋藏了
part of 50 years until the larger story of Buck v. Spell became public. Before she died, Vivian, the child who was deemed to be not quite normal, had been on the honor roll. After the Supreme Court decision, the nation embraced forced sterilizations for decades. The last of the country's eugenics laws were repealed only in the 1970s, by then, some 65,000 Americans had been sterilized. The targets were almost always the least powerful. Native American and African American women, immigrants, the physically and mentally ill, and of course, the poor.
近50年的时间，直到巴克诉贝尔案的宏大故事公之于众。在她去世之前，这个被认为“不太正常”的孩子曾荣登荣誉榜。最高法院作出裁决后，这个国家欣然接受了数十年的强制绝育。该国的最后一部分优生学法律直到20世纪70年代才被废除，到那时，大约有65,000名美国人被实施了绝育手术。目标几乎总是那些最无权无势的人。美洲印第安人和非裔美国女性、移民、身心患病者，当然还有穷人。
As Paul puts it, if you want to know who was going to get sterilized during the reign of the eugenicists, you just had to look at the social ladder and see who was at the bottom. When we come back, we consider the painful legacy of the Virginia State colony for epileptics and feeble minded, and how far we've really come. People would come up to my parents and they would say what happened to her, they would say, can she talk, they would say what's wrong with her? Stay with us. The Virginia State colony was built on a vast track to farmland overlooking the James River.
正如保罗所说，如果你想知道谁会在优生学统治期间被绝育，你只需要看看社会阶梯，看看谁在最底层。当我们回来时，我们将探讨弗吉尼亚州癫痫和智力低下者收容所痛苦的遗产，以及我们到底走了多远。人们会走到我父母面前说她怎么了，他们会说她会说话吗，他们会说她怎么了？请继续收听。弗吉尼亚州收容所建在俯瞰詹姆斯河的一片广阔的农田上。
It's a beautiful spot in the foothills of the Blue Ridge Mountains. It's the kind of country that imprints itself on a person, becomes part of who you are. Molly McAlley Brown grew up just 15 miles from the Virginia colony. I had a lovely childhood. I have a wonderful family, wonderful parents, and I really loved that place. And I really like still, and I think I still benefit from being someone who really feels like they're from someplace, who feels really profoundly attached to a part of the world. I can tell if I'm driving, I can always tell the minute I hit that part of Virginia, sort of, no matter if I can see a sign or not, the landscape starts to look familiar and my heartbeat settles down and I feel like, oh, this is what
那是蓝岭山脉山麓的一个美丽地方。这是那种会给一个人留下印记的乡村，成为你的一部分。莫莉·麦考利·布朗在距离弗吉尼亚收容所以东仅15英里的地方长大。我有一个快乐的童年。我有一个美满的家庭，优秀的父母，我真的很喜欢那个地方。我真的很喜欢，而且我认为我仍然受益于作为一个真正觉得自己来自某个地方的人，一个对世界某一部分有着深厚感情的人。我能分辨出来，如果我在开车，我总能分辨出我到达弗吉尼亚那部分的时刻，无论我是否能看到标志，风景开始变得熟悉，我的心跳平静下来，我觉得，哦，这就是
the world is supposed to look like. And that's a really nice artifact, I think, of having been raised in some place, of knowing where I'm from. The Virginia colony was part of the landscape of her childhood. Molly says that when she and her mother would drive past it on their way to shop at Lynchburg, she would press her nose to the window and stare at the red brick buildings. They looked haunted. I knew that it had this complicated history tangled up with Apple Acha and the Great Depression
世界本来的样子。我认为，在一个地方长大，知道自己来自哪里，是一个非常美好的经历。弗吉尼亚收容所是她童年风景的一部分。莫莉说，当她和母亲开车经过它去林奇堡购物时，她会把鼻子贴在车窗上，盯着那些红砖建筑。它们看起来像闹鬼。我知道它有着与阿巴拉契亚和大萧条交织在一起的复杂历史
and people with disabilities, and I knew that it was still a residential facility for adults with really severe disabilities, but I didn't know much else beyond that. In time, she learned about the institution's troubled history. For Molly, the story of Carrie and Doris Buck came with a special kind of pain. When she looked at her own body, when she thought of the way its strangers looked at her own body, when she thought of the way strangers looked at her, she knew deep down. The colony was meant to house people just like her. Molly has cerebral palsy. I have impaired balance and I walk with a kind of crouched gate.
以及残疾人，我知道它仍然是一个为重度残疾成年人提供住宿的设施，但我对此知之甚少。随着时间的推移，她了解了该机构坎坷的历史。对莫莉来说，嘉莉和多里斯·巴克的故事带有某种特殊的痛苦。当她看着自己的身体，当她想到陌生人看她身体的方式时，当她想到陌生人看她的方式时，她内心深处知道。收容所旨在容纳像她这样的人。莫莉患有脑瘫。我的平衡能力受损，走路时有一种蹲伏的步态。
She often uses a wheelchair. Molly has lived all her life knowing what it's like to be viewed as Albert Pretty might say, as unfit. People would come up to my parents and they would say what happened to her, they would say, can she talk, they would say what's wrong with her. And I think mostly, mostly those questions didn't come out of any kind of malice, they came out of discomfort and curiosity and a lack of understanding. But I understood because of things like that. From a very early age, I understood my body as something strange and other and defective
她经常坐轮椅。莫莉一生都知道被视为阿尔伯特·普里蒂所说的那种“不合格”是什么感觉。人们会走到我父母面前说她怎么了，他们会说她会说话吗，他们会说她怎么了。我想大多数情况下，这些问题并不是出于任何恶意，而是出于不适、好奇和缺乏理解。但我懂，因为诸如此类的事情。从很小的时候起，我就把我的身体理解为一种奇怪的、异类的和有缺陷的东西
and that people were encountering it in that way and then assuming that I was other and defective and strange. Defective and strange. Defective and strange. Words so similar to those ones used to describe the residents of the colony. Molly felt the connection, and once summer, when she was home on college break, she decided to visit the colony grounds. When I was there, I was just really struck by the place I drove to the cemetery, you know, which had gravestones from the very early 1900s up to, you know, just a few years prior to tell me when I was there. And I drove through the facility itself, which because it was built on an enormous
人们就是这样遇到它的，然后假设我是异类的、有缺陷的和奇怪的。有缺陷的和奇怪的。有缺陷的和奇怪的。这些词与用来形容收容所居民的词如此相似。莫莉感受到了这种联系，有一次夏天，当她放暑假在家时，她决定去收容所参观。当我在那里时，我真的对那个地方印象深刻，我开车去了墓地，你知道，那里有从1900年代初到几年前的墓碑，告诉我我在那里。我开车穿过了设施本身，因为它建在一个巨大的
amount of land, still had standing on it, all of the buildings that were the original colony buildings that had just been sort of abandoned and moved out of and then beside them there were these newer functional buildings that were the current facility. And that combination of this place which was both a functioning residential facility and also a kind of ghost town of everything that it had been was really evocative for me. And there's a little plaque kind of at the entrance to the colony that talks a little bit about its history. And again standing in the cemetery, I just remember thinking, oh, if I've been born in the same part of the world, even 60 years earlier, I might well
土地面积上，上面仍然矗立着所有最初的收容所建筑，这些建筑刚刚被某种程度上废弃并搬走，在它们旁边有这些更新的功能性建筑，即当前的设施。这种地方的结合，既是一个功能性的住宅设施，也是它曾经的一切的鬼城，对我很具有启发性。收容所入口处有一个小牌匾，上面简要介绍了它的历史。再次站在墓地里，我只记得当时想，哦，如果我出生在世界的同一个地方，哪怕早60年，我也很可能会
have been a prime candidate to be a colony patient, and that is a kind of amazing, that was an amazing realization for me. Slowly, the idea for a book emerged, a book of poems. She called it the Virginia Colony for epileptics and feeble-minded. Here's Molly reading the first poem in the collection, inspired by those drives she took as a child. Whatever it is, home or hospital, graveyard or asylum, government facility or great tract of land
完全有可能成为收容所的病人，这对我来说是一种惊人的、不可思议的领悟。渐渐地，一本诗集的构想浮现了。她将其命名为“弗吉尼亚癫痫与智障收容所”。这里是莫莉在朗读诗集中的第一首诗，灵感来自于她小时候开车经过的那些地方。无论它是什么，是家还是医院、墓地还是精神病院、政府设施还是大片土地
slowly seating itself back to dust, its church is a low slung brick box with a single window, a white piece of plywood labeled chapel, and a locked door. Whatever it is, my mother and I ride along its red roads in February with the windows down. This place looks lived in, that one has stiff gray curtains in the window, a roof caving in.
慢慢地回归尘土，它的教堂是一个低矮的砖砌盒子，只有一个窗户、一块写着“小教堂”的白色胶合板和一个锁着的门。无论它是什么，我和母亲在二月沿着它红色的土路行驶，车窗摇下。这个地方看起来像是有人住过，那个地方的窗户挂着僵硬的灰色窗帘，屋顶正在坍塌。
We see a small group moving in the channel between one building and the next, bowing in an absent wind. He's in a wheelchair, she is stumbling, pushing a pram from decades ago, cold black and wrong. There is no way it holds a baby. Behind them, a few more shuffling bodies and coats. a few more shuffling bodies and coats. I am my own kind of damaged there, looking out the right hand window. Spastic, paulseed, and off-balance. I'm taking crooked notes about this place. It is the land where he is buried, the place she spent her whole life, the room where they made it impossible for her to have children.
我们看到一小群人在一栋建筑和另一栋建筑之间的通道里移动，在无风的环境中鞠躬。他坐在轮椅上，她跌跌撞撞地推着一辆几十年前的婴儿车，冰冷、黑色而诡异。这绝不可能装得下一个婴儿。在他们身后，又是几个拖着步子的身影和外套。又是几个拖着步子的身影和外套。我在那里也有我自己的受损方式，看着右手边的窗户。痉挛、步履蹒跚、失去平衡。我正在记下关于这个地方的歪歪扭扭的笔记。这就是他被埋葬的土地，她度过一生的地方，也是他们让她无法生育的房间。
It is the colony where he did not learn to read, but did paint every single slat of fence you see that shade of yellow. The place she didn't want to leave when she finally could because she lived there 50 years and couldn't drive a car or remember the outside or trust anyone to touch her gently. And by some accident of luck or grace some window less than half a century wide it is my backyard but not what happened to my body. Most of the poems in Molly's collection are written from the point of view of patience but a few are written in the voices of colony staff. In a section of the book called the infirmary Molly writes from the perspective of a colony
这是他没有学会认字，却把你能看到的每一根栅栏条都刷成那种黄色调的收容所。这是她终于可以离开时却不想离开的地方，因为她在那里住了50年，不会开车，记不清外面的世界，也不相信任何人能温柔地触碰她。由于某种运气或恩典的偶然，某个不到半个世纪宽的窗户，它是我的后院，但不是我的身体所经历的。莫莉诗集中的大多数诗都是从病人的角度写的，但也有少数几首是用收容所工作人员的声音写的。在书中名为“医务室”的一个章节中，莫莉从一个收容所
doctor. A dictionary of hereditary defects. It is shocking really how many ways a being can go wrong before they're even born into the world. Creanism. You are caught between human and animal, heavy and flat faced. You have hoofs for hands, a cow's wide tongue. Epilepsy, you are destroying yourself from the inside out.
医生的角度写作。遗传缺陷词典。一个生命在出生到这个世界上之前能以多少种方式出错，实在令人震惊。克汀病。你介于人和动物之间，笨重而扁平。你的手是蹄子，舌头像牛一样宽。癫痫，你正在从内到外地摧毁自己。
Feeble mindedness, I could shout into the cavern of your mouth and hear my own words echo back off the high walls of your head over all the blank space of your brain. This is the most useful noise that you will ever make. It easy. You cannot even reproduce my echo. You are living yet already your body has started to decay. It knows you are not for this world. You go limp or spastic, turn to stone or slime. At home I drown the smallest kitten in the litter, hold its head under the water for a minute. I feel its heart stop with my thumb. It's done. You are not for this world. It would be cruel to let you replicate yourself and make another creature faded to crawl around
智力低下，我可以朝你嘴巴的深渊大喊，听到我自己的声音从你头部的高墙上、从你大脑的所有空白处回荡回来。这是你这辈子能发出的最有用的噪音。这很简单。你甚至无法复制我的回音。你活着，但你的身体已经开始腐烂。它知道你不属于这个世界。你变得软弱无力或痉挛，变成石头或黏液。在家裡，我淹死了窝里最小的一只小猫，把它的头按在水下一分钟。我用大拇指感觉到它的心跳停止了。完成了。你不属于这个世界。如果让你复制自己，制造出另一个注定要四处爬行的生物，那就太残酷了
feeble and stunted yowling for absent milk. I asked Molly why she wanted to feature the voices of Colony Staff. It is easy from the present moment always to look back at what feel like the kind of atrocities or injustices of our past and think, oh, okay, the people who perpetrated that were monstrous. They were nothing like me. They were evil. They were nothing like my family. They belonged to a world that is entirely unlike the world around us. And to think, oh, we're at a comfortable, far removed distance from that time or from doing something like that.
虚弱、发育不良、为没有母乳而号啕大哭。我问莫莉，为什么她想突出收容所工作人员的声音。身处当下，回望那些感觉像是我们过去的暴行或不公正的事情时，总是很容易认为，哦，好吧，那些犯下罪行的人是怪物。他们一点也不像我。他们是邪恶的。他们一点也不像我的家人。他们属于一个与我们周围的世界完全不同的世界。并且会想，哦，我们与那个时代或做那种事保持着舒适、遥远的距离。
And I think one of the things I wanted to do by having poems in the voices of colony stuff, of the doctors and religious leaders and nurses and attendants who worked in the place, was to say, no, these people were in fact quite human. We're motivated by fear. We're motivated by misunderstanding. We're motivated by anxiety, by visceral disgust, by all kinds of things that we still feel. And that in fact, this wasn't a sort of atrocity undertaken by monsters.
我想，通过让收容所员工、医生、宗教领袖、护士和在那里工作的服务人员用他们的声音写诗，我想做的事情之一就是说，不，这些人实际上非常有人性。我们受恐惧驱使。我们受误解驱使。我们受焦虑、本能的厌恶以及我们仍然能感受到的各种事情驱使。事实上，这并不是一场由怪物发动的暴行。
It was a campaign undertaken by deeply flawed human beings. While campaigns of mass sterilization are in our past, the ideas that inspired those campaigns live on. Dozens of women were sterilized without their consent in the California prison system between 2005 and 2011. In 2017, a judge in Tennessee offered reduced jail time to inmates who agreed to be sterilized in order to, quote, break a vicious cycle of repeat drug offenders with children. The eugenicists were utopians, convinced that they were doing hard but necessary things.
这是一场由充满严重缺陷的人类发动的运动。虽然大规模绝育运动已成过去，但启发这些运动的思想依然存在。2005年至2011年间，加州惩教系统中有数十名女性在未征得同意的情况下被绝育。2017年，田纳西州的一名法官向同意接受绝育的囚犯提供减刑，以“打破有孩子的惯犯的恶性循环”。优生学家是空想家，坚信他们在做艰难但必要的事情。
As much as we might like to relegate their actions to the history books, it's important to pay attention, to make sure we are not carrying their ideas with us in a new addition, freshly bound, shining with the possibility of a brighter future. Today's show was produced by Jenny Schmidt and Thomas Liu with fact-checking by Laura Quarelle. It was edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Raina Cohen and Pat Scha. Kevin Beasley did our voiceovers of Francis Galton. Our unsung hero this week is Wendy Blair, who was reporting 38 years ago, and sure that
尽管我们可能愿意把他们的行为归入历史书，但注意保持警惕非常重要，确保我们没有把他们的想法以新版本、新装订、闪烁着更光明未来可能性的方式带在我们身边。今天的节目由詹妮·施密特和托马斯·刘制作，劳拉·夸雷尔负责事实核查。塔拉·博伊尔负责编辑。我们的团队包括雷娜·科恩和帕特·沙查。凯文·比斯利为弗朗西斯·高尔顿配音。我们本周的无名英雄是温迪·布莱尔，她在38年前进行报道，并确保
Carrie Bach's voice was not erased from her own story. Thank you, Wendy. For more hidden brand, you can find us on Facebook and Twitter and listen for my stories on your local public radio station. You can also listen for our radio show, which is carried on many stations around the country. If you like this episode, please write a review on iTunes or whichever platform you listen to podcasts on. It really helps other people find our show. I'm Shankar Vidantam, and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
卡丽·巴赫的声音没有从她自己的故事中被抹去。谢谢你，温迪。想要了解更多隐藏品牌，你可以在Facebook和Twitter上找到我们，并在你当地的公共广播电台上收听我的故事。你也可以收听我们的广播节目，该节目在全国许多电台播出。如果你喜欢这一集，请在iTunes或你收听播客的任何平台上写一篇评论。这真的能帮助其他人找到我们的节目。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是NPR。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。